tomorrow night a legion stadium opens
preseason football action for the las
vegas raiders they're hosting seattle
the seahawks for the first time raider
nation will get to be inside fans though
if you're going make sure that silver
and black you're there at least three
hours before kickoff hector mejia live
at allegion stadium to explain how the
stadium is going to deal with another
round of traffic and parking issues
hector good morning
good morning exciting weekend but we
also have those issues we've been seeing
for weeks that advisory about arriving
at least three hours early posted on the
raiders website it also has sort of an
hour-by-hour guide telling fans two
o'clock is when the parking lots open
then at three o'clock that's when the
vip entrances along with the general
admission gates open
kickoff six o'clock in the evening and
also it'll be game time for the parking
issues the legion stadium's last major
event came to town uh when the last
major event came to town was the gold
cup final that was earlier this month
with over 61 000 fans many said they ran
into parking and traffic issues those
major problems we also saw during the
garth brooks concert back in july
now the stadium area is represented by
commissioner michael nafta who says the
stadium is working on it they've been
making changes to traffic control
signage and how they're communicating
with people who come down here but fans
from previous events were left with a
sour taste with the stadium's traffic
nightmare
it just didn't seem like they were just
woefully unprepared
to handle
um
a group of people that large which is
just
really absurd we got out on the freeway
and started walking to the event center
it took it was about two miles i saw
actually two ladies have to be taken by
a stretcher walked to an ambulance
because they were passing out from the
heat
well since the garth brooks concert
commissioner michael naft said they
moved the rideshare lot to the other
side of the stadium they added signage
at other places and they improved the
water stations along the hacienda bridge
which is open right now but we'll close
for foot traffic tomorrow he said they
also added misters and shade for staff
and also remember if you're coming to
the game tomorrow masks are required
inside regardless of vaccination status
that's also posted on the raiders
website reporting live outside of legion
stadium hector mejia 8 news now and of
course on the other end of hacienda
you've got the las vegas strip where the
big tailgate event is going to be in
front of the luxor so that's going to be
a big event as well hector thank you
very much appreciate that sir it's now 6
35. now during our mornings with metro
segment this week we spoke with
assistant sheriff andrew walsh about the
parking and the transportation at
allegiant here's what he had to say
look we understand how frustrating it is
you know and
i think that with a lot of the uh events
we've already had that you have a lot of
locals that go and we're used to locally
being able to just pull up and go and
park and go into wherever it is we're
trying to get to uh
the other events you know if we have a
mixture of
locals and tourists it could change the
dynamics of people trying to get there
but uh you know in the in the heat you
know water and if you especially if
you're walking uh we've seen some cases
where people become dehydrated while
waiting to get into the stadium so you
have to take care of yourself in this
weather and you know we know how warm it
is here up until about october so
it's important that everybody just comes
prepared have some water take your time
be patient and if you can get there as
early as possible
but please don't think you're just going
to show up pull up jump out of the car
and walk in to the arena it's not going
to happen
and again sort of the big pregame event
is going to be over on the las vegas
trip in front of the luxor manly bay
area so
meanwhile here's a look at some of your
options to get to allegiant stadium bus
passes eight dollars there are dedicated
routes right to allegiant from around
the valley expect uber and lyft rides to
be pretty expensive because of surge
pricing stadium parking if you can find
it one hundred
now lyft is offering ten dollars off
your ride to the game tomorrow if you
punch in the code ride smart fans as
just one word you'll get that ten dollar
discount the deal starts saturday at
noon tomorrow the first one thousand
riders will get that discount
well raider nation will be in full force
as you would imagine at allegiant
stadium and that includes danny neary in
his 1967 gorgeous metallic blue chevy
impala
he's already been showing up to cheer on
the team at training camp down in
henderson the low rider low low low
bounces around it's all decked out in
raider gear mary's been part of raider
nation since the team called la home and
he moved to vegas to follow the team
67 impala convertible
it's a
blue pearl metallic
it's custom
that you can see
you know and like i said i'm always
coming out here to support my raiders
what do you think of the raiders this
year what do you think oh
i hope they do a lot better i mean they
should what a lot of the new drafts that
we got and the players we got so i think
we're going to do pretty good this year